l'ouverture de la quinzaine du commerce
équitable c'est une goutte d'eau dans
les échanges mais qui continue à grossir
qui a du succès en france et qui s'étend
à tous les domaines voici par exemple le
tourisme équitable
de quoi s'agit-il pour simplifier disons
que le voyageur n'est plus seulement un
spectateur
il s'agit de s'intéresser aux autres à
leur mode de vie nouer des liens et
éventuellement donner un coup de main
nous avons suivi l'un de ces groupes au
niger c'est le dossier de cette édition
il est signé dorothée cauche à
fredericton arrivé du vol paris agadez
ces touristes ne sont pas des touristes
comme les autres pour leurs vacances ils
ont choisi de pratiquer du tourisme
équitable pas d' hôtel 3 étoiles pas de
piscine mais des virées en 4 4 à la
découverte de la population locale le
couple durant vient pour la première
fois d'autres comme sylvie et odile sont
presque des habitués en fait et il ya
des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
nécessaire qu'est ce qu'on a et à chaque
fois dans le village la femme du
tailleur ne s'attend pas au retour de
sylvie qui est passé il ya trois ans et
qui apporte la machine à coudre
électrique keller avait alors promise
le tailleur est à la ville son frère se
chargent de remercier sylvie pour ce
présent qui va changer la vie de toute
la famille
les gabonais mais c'est fait les photos
le tourisme équitable ça commence par
quelques menus cadeaux mais des cadeaux
que l'on a soit lu éléments choisis en
fonction des besoins pour la moment des
cadeaux que l'on ne prend pas n'importe
comment on passe par exemple par les
chefs de famille où les instituteurs
pour respecter la hiérarchie en place et
vous remercie d'une façon tellement
moment fort dans ce sens ce petit les
cavistes vont ainsi jouer les papas noël
pendant huit jours des touristes aisés
pour la plupart et qui en plus des
caisses de présents ont payé 1600 euros
leur voyage est ce que j'achète pas une
bonne conscience en faisant ça je crois
pas vraiment pas du tout pas eu en tous
les cas parce que on s'achète une bonne
conscience quand on envoie un chèque ce
qui est bien aussi âgé quand on envoie
un chèque à une association quand on
fait un geste mais là ça s'inscrit dans
la continuité et je voudrais pas que ce
genre de voyage devienne une mode des
pics n'importe qui se lance là dedans
parce que là cela se fait contrer
c'est ce qui est surprenant c'est de
voir des tweets art est bien sûr dans
tourisme équitable
il ya tourisme on apprend beaucoup
notamment les modes de vie locaux est ce
qu'on peut faire du fromage avec le lait
des chameaux des chats mais non on
n'arrive pas à les faire gagner deux cas
les icaunais
et on apprend aussi la patience
légendaire est nécessaire des touareg au
fur et à mesure que les jours passent au
fil du bac les touristes nous des liens
avec les guides ils apprennent le
système des locales
bref il touche du doigt ce qui a motivé
leur voyage doit se partager un petit
peu je dis palme être équitable il doit
se partagent un petit peu donc de
voyager autrement en neuf ans les yeux
je pense que ça mais ça me fait le monde
quoique ma propre vie on peut être est
égoïste on notre quotidien janice
intéresse des problèmes des gens de
payer les prochains les problèmes des
nomades qui sont ici d'erreur culture
les mains de ceux qui peuvent les
apporter
les hôtels seront prêts et le moment le
plus important de leur voyage
c'est celui ci
de l'eau en plein désert l'aboutissement
d'un an de travail
les hommes de la famille montre combien
leur destin a changé depuis la création
de ce puits 1 puis financé par quelques
personnes de notre groupe et qui permet
de nourrir 12 personnes
on voit que ces gens là c'est la
condition pour qu'ils vivent donc c'est
vrai que notre regard pour nous et on a
envie quand on rentre de le transmettre
chacun repartira avec le nouveau projet
monter une chorale fondée l'association
réunir toutes les bonnes volontés pour
financer un nouveau puits les voyages
les plus forts ne sont ils pas
finalement ceux qui ont une seconde vie